hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled keynote presentation the
virus the host and the battle for
survival how viruses interact with the
host ubiquitin machinery to promote
successibility and resistance to
infection this webinar is part of the
2021 microbiology virtual week and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots now let's get started before
we begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and as a reminder the
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located on the top right hand corner of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr ricardo
rajban an associate professor of the
department of microbiology and
immunology at the university of texas
medical branch for a complete biography
of our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr rajvon welcome you may now begin your
presentation morning everybody
first of all thank you so much for lab
roots for the invitation to give this
talk
and to be able to share with you um some
of the work that we are doing
um
and which which we think is very timely
uh during this
uh terrible copy pandemic to understand
how different viruses
are able to
replicate
and adapt
to the whole cells
so um
to start um
upon virus infection
the whole cell can recognize
the virus infection
via
pattern recognition receptors that are
expressed in different compartments in
the cell
and upon recognition trigger multiple
second signaling cascades that
result in the expression of different
cytokines
these cytokines have different
functions during viral infection
one of these hypothesis that they are
particularly interested in is type 1
interference because are well known to
have antiviral effects
so
this interference
can
act
by
triggering their own signaling cascades
through a receptor in neighboring cells
and
these results in the expression of
interference stimulated genes or isgs
which are proteins that
can directly uh have antibiotic effects
by interacting with
with viruses um but obviously if this
was uh
perfect we would never get infected so
viruses have evolved to express
uh proteins
that can antagonize these responses and
basically can antagonize each of the
steps that i'm showing in this slide
but we're particularly interested on the
interactions that happen between these
viral antagonists
and the antiviral
the host antiviral effectors that can
lead to some evolutionary pressure to
the virus and and and allow the virus to
adapt and use these antiviral effects
for their own advantage so um we we're
really interested in looking how these
potentially antiviral factors can be
utilized by the viruses for for uh for
their own advantage um so what i'm going
to tell you here
um it's um
examples of different viruses that have
been we have been studying um
that include the nipah virus ebola virus
influenza and zika and i'll touch a
little bit on star scope too
so um
to to zoom in a little bit more on these
pathways and specifically the rig ipad
which is a pattern recognition receptor
that can
recognize viral rna when when a
virus infects cells and trigger this
specific signaling pathway and what i
want to focus here is in on on
on these kindnesses that are called tdk1
and ik epsilon uh that can phosphorylate
transcription factors irf3 and rf7 that
translocate to the nucleus for
production of type 1 interference
um so basically these pathways have to
be
highly regulated so we do not have
excessive inflammation this would cause
problems if we have too much
inflammation uh even interference can be
bad if they are expressing high levels
um so these post-translational
modifications like phosphorylation can
turn on and off these pathways so
another
transitional modification that we're
interested in studying is ubiquitination
which is
mostly study for
modification of proteins that are
targeted to the gradation by the
proteosome but ubiquitination has many
other functions and like phosphorylation
can can regulate activate or or
deactivate these pathways
and there are different types of
polyurethane chains that have different
functions
so um ubiquitin is a small protein it's
a 76
amino acid protein
that the way
it functions is that
modifies
um proteins
via its c-terminal uh glycine glycine
residues
that modified color covalently modified
i like usually a lysine in a target
protein
so this
um
in addition to this since ubiquitin
itself has seven lysines
each of these lysines can be modified by
another ubiquitin to form these
polyurethane chains this is important
but because depending on the ubiquitin
chain that it can be formed like for
example um one of the ones that is most
studies lysine 48
would be putting chains that are
targeted to the projection for
degradation um
have that function but there are these
other chains that are uh less study and
have non-degradatory functions
so and and and
the way
why is it important is this how does it
work why is it that the the the chain
depending on what what the license is
modified the chain would be different
and really is the topology of the chains
how how here is an example of how when
you have a lysine 48
linkage um you have one type of of
topology or shape of the chain and when
you have a lysin63 you can have a
different type of photo of shape and
and these would change how all the
proteins interact with the ubiquitin
wiggling the protein so so in general um
proteins that are going to lead to
signaling cascades are recruited or
interact with
ubiquitinated proteins and require
or have ubiquitin binding domains that
is like a log and a key they have to
match so they can interact and
efficiently with high affinity and from
complexes that lead to signaling
cascades
so the ubiquitination process um
requires the activity of three enzymes
an e1 activating enzyme
in the presence of the atp as an energy
source and liquidity
and e2 conjugates and anit3 ligase
the e3 ligase is really important
because
is the one that it
is required for recognition of the
substrate or the protein that is going
to be ubiquitinated so the e3 recognizes
the e2
conjugates together with the substrate
and transfers ubiquitin um to form these
polypeptide chains that
um will lead to a specific function
depending on the type of ubiquitin can
be degradation by the proteosome or many
other functions depending on the polio
between chain
um we are particular there are about 600
e3 lyrics that are encoded by the human
genome we are particularly interested in
a on a one of these families that is
called a
tripartite motif or trim proteins there
are it's compostable
over 70 members in humans
and and contain this specific
domain a ring a bibox domain and a cocco
domain and different trends can contain
different c-terminal regions
and why why are we so interested in this
string family
the reason is because
um indeed in 2004
it was discovered that trin5 alpha could
could have
um antiviral activity um
against um
hiv specifically the african green
monkey and macarthur and five alpha
could restrict hiv so in since then a
lot of work
was was done on studying retroviruses
and how multiple trains could
potentially inhibit directly
or restrict these these viruses um but
it took a long time until
really trims took off and other studies
were looking at all their forms
other types of
regulation in terms of antiviral
activity strings can have many other
functions like cell differentiation
transcription regulation
they are we'll be putting ligases so you
would expect them to be involved in many
functions
um so
so really the role of trims
um there were a few studies that
appeared to show that trims could also
regulate scene in pathways but really
the major discovery i think it was in in
2007 when uh uh
mikhail agar discovered that 25 could be
putting an agriguy
to trigger that signaling pathway to to
induce interference
since then a lot of studies have focused
on how trims can also regulate
um
in
inflammatory pathways or interferon
pathways and another thing that can
connect this with the
um antiviral responses is that many of
these strings themselves are inducible
by interferon um
so
so
um
you know having like uh
an enhancement loop that would increase
the expression of these genes and allow
them to have their functions
um
we then perform a a screen on on
multiple on the 70 members
of the trim family and we found that a
large number of them
can have
functions positive functions in
regulating uh signaling pathways and you
can think about this as also having
effects indirectly against
viruses because if you are regulating
positively the interference response and
interferon eventually will induce
antiviral
proteins
so this is something that we have been
very interested in looking you know how
how chains regulate
uh interferon and other inflammatory
pathways
um so this is just an example of how
many trims and there are more to these
uh already that can
have both negative and positive
functions
in regulation of pattern recognition
receptor signaling so upon
antivirus or pathogens um
many things can have been shown to have
to regulate these pathways uh mostly
beyond
of of uh signaling factors um one of
the proteins that we focused on
after our screen
um
it was stream six
uh which i'm gonna tell you a little bit
more about
so uh for this again i wanna draw your
attention to the kindnesses tvk1 and ikk
epsilon that i mentioned before that are
responsible for phosphorylation that
this of irs iii and r7
and for a long time we're known to play
redundant roles um in phosphorylation of
higher clinic seven so in the absence of
ikk epsilon tpk one could compensate um
but um
you know later
in
in 2007 it was discovered that ikk
epsilon
has a non-redundant role that can
phosphorylate one side
on stat one that helps the formation of
these complex the isc f3 complex stat
one stat two irf9 there are
transcription factors um this complex
translocates the nucleus and it's
required for the induction of these
interference stimulated genes and
setting 708 helps
phosphorylation of this site helps the
formation of
a stable complex
but how the ikk epsilon
is activated was not known for a long
time and so during these studies we
found that
3m6
can
make can synthesize these type of
polyubiquity chains
um k-48 politician chains but these type
of proliferation chains in particular
are not covalently attached to any
protein
so they do not
link
covalently to ikea epsilon and targeted
for degradation what this do actually is
to promote protein protein interactions
so promote oligomerization of ikk
excellent and this activates ikk epsilon
helps its cross phosphorylation that
leads to its active full activation for
um so it's able to to phosphorylate its
substrates like stat1 or or irf3 and rf7
um so basically we elucidated a
molecular mechanism by which stream 6
can activate interferon pathways and we
demonstrated that this could be
important in controlling uh
especially influential virus replication
and i will tell you a little bit more
about the viruses that we have been
studying but what is important is that
this is
a an unconventional type of polyurethane
chain it's not regular the regular type
of polyurethanes that are studied these
are difficult to study because they are
not commonly attached so there are a lot
of experiments that need to be done to
dissect and uh demonstrate that the
chains are not covalently attached um
and and and can lead to different
functions
so so after this if we were asking
questions like if 36 is indeed a very
important
fact or host factor in the induction of
antiviral responses then we hypothesize
that there might be viruses that would
antagonize it
so we started looking for viruses the
viruses that would that were already
known to
to to to antagonize uh the interferon
pathway by targeting specifically ikk
epsilon since this is
the the substrate uh that we found
fortune 6.
so um
so
um by asking this question we could also
ask whether the inhibition of ikea
epsilon was
via
blocking the activity of trin6
and so so this part of this project was
published
in 2016 and uh um this was done by a
host of them in my lab i pre raj and it
was a huge collaboration um
with with all
um other labs
um
so so
the the interesting thing is that by by
that time our collaborator in mount
sinai ben hurley had found that the
matrix protein of nipah virus
could could inhibit ik epsilon and
that's how we wanted to to to narrow
down the mechanism so nipah virus is a
highly pathogenic virus
uh that um
has had outbreaks
uh in in in asia
um it has high mortality rates it has to
be
we have to work with it in these high
containment facilities in bsl4
um
um
it's it's it can be transmitted it's the
reservoir is believed to be the bats and
can be transmitted to to other
animals and to humans and uh there have
been reports of human to human
transmission and it can have respiratory
effects and also encephalitis and other
problems but it's it's a very highly
pathogenic pathogenic virus
um
so so how how
what
uh sonipa virus um
when it infects cells like other viruses
releases his genome and allows the
genome to replicate um so once the
proteins are expressed um this protein
that i was telling you about the matrix
protein it's actually a very interesting
protein because it's a structural
protein it's it was known to to be
important for
for budding of of
of the virus um
so it's required for the formation of
viral particles and release um um but
something that was not known is that the
matrix protein required trafficking it
was it needed to go to the nucleus and
then be transported to the membrane to
package the virus and it was not known
what this trafficking
meant or why was it needed for the virus
and uh our collaborators and eventually
discovered that there was this site k258
that was required for this trafficking
um so
um we use this this this mutant um
you'll see in a minute because um it
actually this trafficking is also
important for the antiviral
for the antagonism that we discover
um so so the question that we ask is
since nipa
the
uh matrix protein could block ikk
epsilon uh we wanted to know if if if
can do it by blocking the binding of an
anchor polyurethane chain that we found
were important for the activation of ikk
um
so the first thing that we did was to
use our lucifer's reported assay so in
this assay uh it's a promoter that is
linked to a a reporter a lucifer's
reporter that can be transfected into
cells and in the presence of ikk epsilon
we can activate this
this reporter um and in the presence of
nepal the
wall type m we can see that there is a
reduction in the in the interference
induction so indeed it's antagonizing
the effects of ik epsilon
um but the use of this mutant the k258a
that cannot traffic uh loses this
activity so actually gives us a good
control um to test the effects of of of
the matrix protein um so the next assay
that we we we use to test whether this
is affecting the interaction of this an
encore k-48 to liquidating chains with
ik epsilon is an immunoprecipitation
assay in which we can overexpress ikk
epsilon um in the presence or absence of
the matrix protein and see what
interactors
or interactions occur uh
um in the presence of ikk epsilon so
what you can see first is that when you
over express ik epsilon
and and we can pull it down you can see
in this western blot that you can detect
this non-core polyurethane chains with
ik epsilon
and um
ikk epsilon actually when it's over
express is active so you can see here
that we we we have high levels of
phosphorylated akap soon um
um
and also you can get interaction with
irf3 which is a substrate downstream and
the irf3 that is interacting with like a
capsule it's phosphorylated so now what
happens when we add we over express
the matrix protein the wild type matrix
protein you see that we lose interaction
with this unknown core polyurethane
chains this result in reduced
phosphorylation of ikk epsilon
um
reduce phosphorylation of irf3 but the
interaction with rf3 is not affected so
it's really the activity of ikk epsilon
that is affected um and by targeting
these ubiquitin chains uh and we can see
that we can recover this at this this
activity in the presence of the uh
uh two private a uh mutant of the matrix
protein which does not inhibit interfere
so um so is it is it this happening via
trim 6 is it
the matrix protein targeting 36 for this
effect um so so we went back to this
luciferase reporter assay and what you
can see is that if we add uh
in the presence of trin6 and interferon
we get an induction so 26 can enhance
the the levels of interference
stimulated genes induced by interferon
and in the presence of the wild type
matrix protein you can see that this
effect is reduced
if we use again the mutant
uh matrix protein we only see minor
effects but the other thing that we
realize in this assays is that we lose
expression of trim six when we over
express the matrix protein suggesting
that maybe the matrix protein may target
36 for
for the relation makes it some or less
stable or something happens to trim six
in the presence of the wild type matrix
um so in another way to demonstrate that
this happens in viral infection um with
the in collaboration with alex freiberg
in using high uh containment facilities
at utm
in dsl4 um
generated um
recombinant viruses that that lack that
lack the matrix protein so he called
delta delta m and as you can see here so
this and and this is in the background
of virus that expresses gfp so you can
see which viruses are infected because
they are fluorescent so you can see that
the cells that are expressing uh gfp um
appear to express less amounts of 26 as
compared to cells that are surrounding
it
that are not infected and you can
compare that also with cells that are
infected with the delta m which do not
appear to reduce
much the levels of um 36 expression
again in suggesting that um the matrix
protein the water matrix protein target
stream six for degradation
so so for this part we think that we
discover
uh a mechanism by a very highly
pathogenic virus in which targets uh
what we
we we described to be an antiviral
protein 36
via interference production and um and
basically targeted for degradation so so
the next question was are there any
other viral proteins that are known
already to target ike epsilon that could
also
have this effect so we looked at
this protein bp35 of ebola virus which
was
described
previously is a very well known
interferon antagonist of ebola virus
and since it had been described before
to target redi tbk and ike epsilon we
wanted to know if this could be also an
effect
uh via trim six
um so ebola virus i'm not gonna talk too
much about it but
in terms of like you all know that it's
very highly pathogenic there have been
outbreaks in africa um
and and it's it's it has caused a lot of
deaths in africa and the the
latest uh outbreak happened in 2020 and
because a lot of uh
cases and deaths deads
and again this virus also has to be
worked within in high containment dsl4
facilities
um so so bp35 is
really
studied a lot for his role as an
antagonist of the interference response
but it also plays a role as co-factor of
the viral polymerase and so so after
infection uh with ebola um and
expression of um
of the different proteins of the uh
of the virus uh bt-35 can complex with
with other uh pro polymerase proteins to
help the virus replicate so it has
different functions and bp35 could could
have different functions in terms of
interferon and and and and replication
um so as i said and the best probably
the best
studied role of bp35 is his antagonistic
role by blocking both uh by sequestering
those standard rna from the from reguy
and mda5 and um
but also targeting ikk and uh tbk and
phosphorylation of rf3 and f7
so we asked this question can bp 35 also
target
uh stream six so what the first thing we
did was to test
uh in immunoprecipitation again it's
like a binding assay to see if string
six could interact with bp35 and indeed
we found interaction of 36 with the 35
but not other
proteins like the
mp protein of the lymphocytic heated
virus
that
also was known to inevitably
um
so
the next question is
you know whether gen 6 has an effect
during a volabile replication so we
generated a 36 knuckle cells
and tested you know the role of stream
six first and during ebola virus
replication and what we could see is as
we expected from the role that we
described
uh that gym six knockout cells um do not
produce much interference uh it was less
interference than
what it says during ebola virus and this
occurs late during infection because as
i said ebola
virus is very good in inhibiting the
response so it only interferes only in
these layers when there is a lot of
virus
but these cells seem to also have some
this regulation because they have more
the knockout cells express more levels
of uh in inflammatory cytokines like io6
cells are dead they are infected and
they they they are responding but it's
just they don't
um induce
much interference so we we expected with
this result that we will have you know
you have less interference we were
expecting to have more virus right
interference antiviral you have less
interference we expect to have more
virus replication in these cells
knockout cells but actually it was the
opposite so these stream six knockout
cells
had less value of replication uh
suggesting that stream six
at least has some role in promoting
viral replication ebola virus
replication so we decided to test
whether this interaction between trim
six and bp35 um
results in in in
ubiquitination of the viral protein and
maybe this is affecting vp35 function so
we we use
um mass spectrometry uh analysis and and
we detected one lysine ubiquitinated in
the c terminal region of bp35 which is
known as the antagonist domain of the
35 with this k lysine 309 residue and we
corroborated that this is ubiquitinated
so this is an uh an assay in which we
overexpress hi tag ubiquitin in the
presence of vp-35 water we're a mutant a
lysine to alanine newton that we would
not get liquid in it on that side and
you can see that these multiple bands
um represent different molecular weights
of bp-35 because it's covalently
ubiquitinated so indeed we can see
liquid in national vp35 and there is a
reduced uh uv coordination of bp35 in
the mutants
there is still some bands which means
that we probably miss some sites in the
mass spectrometry and there are other
sites from vp35 that might be
ubiquitinated
besides k309 but these mutants may allow
us to to to study what is the role
specifically in k309 of ubiquitination
um
so then we we
we try to confirm that trim six indeed
has a role on regulating vp35 and in
this assay um it's animal precipitation
again um in which we pull down vp35 but
in the presence of absence of stream six
and you can see in the presence of trend
six we we we can see in enhanced
ubiquitination of bt-35 we if we use the
knockout cells and we over express bp35
and pull it down uh we can see that in
tune six knuckle cells that is reduced
ubiquitination of vp35 so indeed stream
six plays a role in liquidation
um so then we set up an assay this is
this is without virus this is a
reporter as a lucifer reporter i'll say
mini genome using only the polymerase
components of the virus as i said vp35
has a function there so by using vp35 we
can test whether the wiretap and the
mutant in the presence of trim six um
would would affect uh
um the polymerase activity and you can
see that when we add trim six to this
assay um we have an enhancement of the
polymerase function of the virus and
when we add that catalytically inactive
form of 26 um and we do not see this
enhancement and if we use this new terms
of vp35
we also do not see the enhancement so
really this should suggest that 3m6
ubiquitinates um
k309 on vp35 and this is important for
polymerase function
we also generated 2 in 6 knockout mice
um and we are doing experiments with
this mice now
but but the first thing that you can see
is that indeed as we see in cells these
streams between six knockout mites is a
little bit more resistant to evolve
virus
infection um and this is probably due
because indeed there is less virus
replication um in some tissues in the 36
knockout mice
um so um
i have shown you two very highly
pathogenic viruses that that um uh can
can can can target from six um so now
i'm gonna i wanna talk about um um
well um this we are still investigating
the mechanism so uh uh
at the molecular level how bbc five
between equilibrium affects replication
and this is work of a graduation lab
sarah
and we hope to to have a manuscript soon
for this uh so now i want to shift to
another virus completely different virus
this various zika virus you probably
heard about it in the past years uh now
with kovis this
basically there's no attention on this
anymore but it doesn't mean that it's
not circulating around uh the the
interesting thing or the the problem
that we have with satsika was that um
it's transmitted by mosquitoes but it
was found
in pregnant women to affect
uh pregnancy and and and it was
associated with with uh
microcephaly in newborns um so the big
question is why the virus likes to
replicate so well in in reproductive
tissues and why is it causing these
these effects so we turn to see if if
anything related with the ubiquitin
system would be be involved in this
um so so the way we did this was similar
to what i talked about before for ebola
which is that we we use infected cells
um and we we perform mass spectrometry
analysis from different from cells
infected with different flaviviruses for
comparison and zika virus here cabi
syncope and we found different viral
proteins that were ubiquitinated
uh here i'm showing you the envelope
protein of zika virus
which was of real interest for us and we
found two different sites that will be
within it on zika virus uh one that is
conserved in other flaviviruses with
this this is lysine 38 and the other one
is non-conserving other fly viruses this
lies in k281
and so we wanted to know what's what the
effects of this subglutination and
whether they have any any relationship
with tropism or with the effects that
they're seeing uh specifically in zika
um
so um
we focus on envelope really because it's
a really important protein it's the main
components of the virion um
and it covers the envelope and and it's
important because it's recognized by
receptors and it's important in entry
um
so uh this was work that we published
recently uh
maria geraldo in the lab uh in
collaboration with this was a huge
collaboration with people inside utmb
and outside and especially especially
peyong she
utmb
and what we did is first is generate
recombinant mutant viruses um
um that have a
an arginine instead of allies in these
two sites um that would
um are the closest possible amino acids
to lysine but they do not get
ubiquitinated so you conserve as much as
possible the structure of of of the
envelope um
with this change but the the arginine
cannot be ubiquitinated and as you can
see here again with over expression of
hi ubiquitin and infected cells you can
see that the wall types uh envelop
envelope from multivirus
we can see a smear that corresponds to
liquidity in an envelope but the other
two parameters lose weight glutamination
um we tested this in uh um
in cells like how does this virus
replicate in in different cell types and
we can see that a placenta derived cell
line
uh where the virus replicates very well
these two viruses are attenuated with
the k38
was the highest effect but
this is a
cell type specific effect so for example
in testis the k281 didn't have much
effect but the case 38r still
uh was very attenuated
and when we look at mosquito cells uh
the virus also repeats very well in
mosquito cells of course because it's
transmitted by mosquitoes but we didn't
see any difference there in these mutant
viruses suggesting that this site and
potentially ubiquitination in this site
is not important in mosquito cells but
it is important in certain cell types
and
so then we tested this
the effects in vivo we infected mice uh
with these viruses and what you can see
there in red the red line is it's um
um the k-38 mutant virus that is
attenuated it basically causes less
disease in this in this in in this mice
so what type
virus can uh makes the the
mice
uh lose more weight and the k21 didn't
have much effect so this this effects
translating survival so the while that
we get some mice that
die but um the mutant viruses uh
uh survive
um so we looked at
replication in different tissues because
this is in the end the question that we
have is if there is this affect this
affects tropism um and it was
interesting to see that
some
tissues like the brain
and testis
where the virus replicates very well the
k-38 was
reduced in virus replication while the
k-21 was not so we looked at more
tissues focusing on the k2 k-38
and interestingly we saw only
differences in tissues where the virus
replicates very well like brain and
reproductive reproductive tissues but
not in other tissues so really this
suggests that the virus do degradation
on k-38 it's important for for tropism
um
and we did experiments using live
mosquitoes after blood meal and we
didn't see any difference in mosquitoes
so again this this site doesn't does not
appear to be important uh in virus
application in the mosquito um
so
what is what how is this happening um we
we obviously had to go back and look at
them at
what's what which one is the e3 like
that is doing this um so to got a long
story short um
we found
um after looking at multiple knockdown
screens
um
and
looking at different potential e3
ligases involved we found this one trim
seven that
um it seems to be highly expressed in
placenta and reproductive tissues and
could be one of these targets so we make
made a 37 knockout cells
and we can see that there is a reduction
of
virus replication in string seven
knuckle cells
and when we use this k-38 our virus
mutants um it really shows a similar
effect to the 27 knockout cells so this
really suggests that trim seven it's
important for efficient virus
replication in these placenta derived
cells and that you need an intact lysine
k38
residue for this replication uh we
tested interaction with stream seven and
infected cells and as we can see here in
this immunoprecipitation essay stream
seven can interact with envelope
we then
wanted to confirm that 37 would be
quitting h
directly enveloped so we established an
in vitro recruiting nation assay
in this assay
what we what we do is that we we used
all the components of the
ubiquitination system um so we use the
an e1 activating enzyme
we used this e2 ligase uvch5a which was
previously already described to act in
conjunction with stream seven so we
didn't discover this when it was already
reported and and we purified trim seven
um uh to add it to this assay and we use
the wall type and the mutant envelope
proteins to demonstrate this in vitro
so in this assay
um
in the presence
so what you can see is that when you add
trim seven to this assay
we can get this shift in the molecular
weight
of envelope
which corresponds
to two bonds that appear for ubiquitin
when using an ubiquitin antibodies so
basically again when you get a wikipedia
nation of envelope this is covalent to
equilibrium so then you have a shift in
the bands upwards and you see the more
trim 7 is added
the more you get increasing these
molecular weight bands that represent we
could need an envelope um
so so what is
um as a control uh we can see that we
use this catalytically inactive trim
seven so it's it's a
deletion of string seven that lacks the
ring domain
we do not get any increase in detonation
we also need atp so in the absence of
atp this reaction does not happen we
need energy source
as an energies of atp
um and
what we can see is that in the presence
of the mutant kt k38r
envelope um we have a reduction of
liquidation as we would expect but it's
not completely gone this is probably due
because of the presence of the other
side the k21 side that is still there
probably still get gets re-coordinated
and we can still see some some envelope
of equity nation but the reduction is
uh it's clear
um and and we can see that in the
presence of the k2a1 mutant almost
completely loses ubiquitination um
so so this really
what indicates is that indeed
in vitro37 can directly ubiquitinate
envelope and two in these two sides in
k-38 and k-21 um and and that they both
probably play a role uh
um and are required for full
ubiquitination of envelope
so
um
then we wanted to test if this is
this has an effect in vivo so we we
generated 37 knockout mice to test
whether
um stream 7 has a role
in virus replication and whether it will
have a role
in tissue tropism
and so what you can see here
really nicely is that
um in string 7 knockouts mice have
reduced virus replication
again in the tissues where the virus
likes to replicate like brain
uh
testis and uterus interesting with here
we also see a defect in the eye maybe
because it also has
a connection with the with the brain and
maybe that that's one of the reasons why
we also see a difference here but we do
not see difference in any other tissues
so uh really again indicating that uh 27
and this ubiquitination may occur in a
tissue specific
manner and it
it it suggests really that trim seven
could be
um um
a determinant of tropism for zika virus
um
so so this is all very nice but we want
to know a little bit more about the
mechanism and how it is occurring and um
so ubiquitination happens in the cell
all the machinery is obviously inside
the cell um i'm not showing you here but
in some experiments we could see that
the uh during infection uh we could find
some relocalization of 27 to some
compartments some vesicles that are seem
to be associated with the golgi um
and
you know suggesting maybe ubiquitination
may happen
during viral replication at later time
points when the virus is maybe being
formed and it's maybe it's being
transported to
to to outside the cell um but you know
most of the ubiquitination
has been studied inside the cell like
there's really not much evidence that
viruses come out of the cell without it
and the data we put in plays a role
there are maybe
only examples with influenza of these
this to happen but we wanted to know
this could be something uh that plays a
role so so we hypothesized that maybe
the reason why we're seeing stream seven
in the golgi and that the virus gets
recreated in the envelope and the
envelope has a very important role in
entry we wanted to know if
the virus that is released contains any
ubiquitin
so for this
um what we did was to collect
supernatants from from infected cells
with zika
we clear them we concentrate them and
clear them as much as possible from
contaminants and what we did was to use
a specific anti
k-63 liquidity antibody for an
immunoprecipitation of
variance if these venus contains some
ubiquitin we will be able to isolate
these variants
that contain weak protein as a control
we also use
an antibody against the envelope protein
to see how much envelope we can pull
down so what you can see here in the in
the left is that when we do this
immunoprecipitation either with the
envelope
antibody and we probe with an antibody
against envelope we can see the band
that corresponds to non-modified uh
envelope which is approximately 48
kilodaltons something like that
right below 50
but then we see this smear that of bands
that go up all the way up
that would correspond to to to possibly
multiple chains of ubiquitin of equity
and if if we compare these with
immunoprecipitation with the mtk63
antibody we can see that the high
molecular weight bands really correlate
with liquidity
and if we then
um re-probe this blood with anti-k63
ubiquitin we can see that these bands
really correlate with the high molecular
weights balance of envelopes really
suggesting that the virion itself
contains
some amount of of envelope that is
ubiquitinated um this doesn't seem to be
complete it's just
a proportion of envelope that seems to
contain liquid
we did something similar like collecting
supernatants from cells from vitamin c
stream seven knuckle knuckle cells to
see if 37 indeed is responsible for this
and we really
we could see that there was a loss of
ubiquitin in in the biryans that were
collected from stream seven knockout
cells
so how else can we do this so we can
really show it how we can we can we more
visually show it so we use this anti-k63
or we could in antibody um and and then
we use a secondary antibody that is
labeled with gold particles and we
perform cryo-em to try to see the actual
viral particles to see if we could
recognize
um you know um
ubiquitin around the the virion so what
you can see here is an example of one of
the particles that we could see so the
little very dark dots that you see
around the the virion um are gold
particles that are recognizing the ntk63
liquid within antibody so what is
interesting about this is that um
we the first thing is that not all the
virion is covered with these
um
particles which suggest that not all the
180 units of an envelope that are
containing the billion are obliterated
and the second is that we we we found
like a small proportion of the viral
particles that contain these gold
particles so maybe about 15 percent from
the preparation uh we could see that had
viral
this called called particles so so i
think this also demonstrates in a in a
more visual way that the virus can
contain some of equity and and and we
can use this case extreme antibody to
recognize it
so if the antibody works well
we also wonder if this antibody would be
neutralizing this anti-k63 we could in
antibody if we mix it with virus
would it be neutralizing with blood
virus replication and indeed what we see
is that if we add increasing amounts of
this
antibody
uh we can reduce the infectivity
of the wall type virus and the k281
mutant virus but not the k38 virus that
is in red
so this again strongly suggests that
indeed the antibody can recognize k63
within chains and and reduce infectivity
of the virus but only um but if
you need that k k 38 site intact um we
use as a control the an antique
ubiquitin until we escape 48 and we saw
very little effects we also wanted to
know if this happens in vivo so we
administer mice with with this anti-k63
with an antibody
and infected mice and what we could see
is
again that this antibody could reduce
um
the levels of virus replication in in at
least in this serum um
when we looked at virus replication uh
in the presence of this antibody
um
so
um
how is this occurring so the virus
contains ubiquitin so is it that
why why does it need ubiquitin the virus
why why why the variance would contain
liquidity so the next obvious question
would be if if this
has any relation to attachment so we we
perform an attachment experiment in
which we incubate cells at four degrees
with with with water bombs and viruses
we let them attach for for 30 minutes of
four degrees and then we collect rna to
measure virus attachment and what we can
see is that indeed multivirus can be
attached to the cells and the k-38
mutant virus is highly reducing the in
the ability to attach to the cells with
just very
um not
very significant reduction in the k-281
and if we shift to 37 degrees we allow
the virus to go inside the cell and we
can see that indeed because there is
less attachment to the to this to the
cell with the k38 mutant there is less
entry so you can detect less virus
entering the cell
with these mutant viruses
finally we wanted to know if this is
related to binding to a receptor there
are a few different receptors that have
been described for for zika but they are
not
it's not clear which one is the most
important there is still a lot of
controversy but we use team one
to test whether this would have an
effect uh in in attachment in
in
attachment to the receptor so in this
assay we we bind team one to the beats
like if it was an amino precipitation
assay and we mix it with virus multiple
mutant virus and what we can see is that
the multivirus
can interact very well with team one um
but the k38r loses this interaction with
team one suggesting that at least
team one uh can have some affinity for
viewing the container equity
um
so so to summarize these parts uh i mean
so what we think that is happening is
that you know the mosquito you know
mosquito transmits zika to to to humans
um
muslim does have an ubiquitin system um
but it's
it's not it's not
it doesn't contain uh the same 37 that
the humans have so it's possible that
the liquidation doesn't happen in the
right place or in the right chains and
in mosquitoes it's not important but
once the mosquito bites and the virus
infects humans the virus is disseminated
it goes to different tissues and when it
goes when it finds the right tissue
where trim 7 is expressing then the
virus
starts repeating replicating better and
this is because there is a
stronger interaction of
of viruses that come out from tissues
that contain 37
because it contains ubiquitin so this
gives an advantage to the virus to
attach better to the receptors and
replicate better in these tissues now
it's not like the absence of ubiquitin
renders completely inactive the virus so
the virus can still replicate but it's
just
has a weaker interactions with the
receptors and the interesting thing is
that trim 7 has been reported to have
other functions like antiviral functions
so so so it's interesting that stream 7
is having different functions uh um um
during replication uh different viruses
it can block neural virus replication
but for sick at least we showed that
it's important in in ubiquitination of
the envelope and allowing some tropism
to occur
so in the last two slides i cannot
ignore kobet obviously this has been a
huge problem we all know about it um
what what it has been really you know we
have learned a lot in the last year and
a half on how
inflammation causes
um disease in in patients um and and how
like with it so the virus infects
epithelial cells but there is
recruitment of immune cells that cause
damage to the tissue and this is due to
really a deregulation of the
immune response and expression of
cytokines especially type and interfere
the interference should be
be beneficial right they should be
blocking virus replication but they also
have an inflammatory role so
um there has been a lot of research
trying to figure out also antagonists of
the interferon response so in
collaboration with peyon she we we did a
screen and we found multiple
viral proteins of sarcopte that could
could block at very different
and multiple levels of these signaling
pathways
to block the antiviral
response
um we interestingly uh found and focus
on on one of these proteins the or 7a
which is an accessory protein that is
not very well known what it does during
viral replication but it's it's known to
be a membrane posterior membrane
associated protein that it may be
involved in in in immune in immune with
this regulation and what we found is
that this orbit 7a is ubiquitinated in
the panel a here you can see that it's
highly obligated
and making mutants we found this lysine
119 um that has reduced regulation and
when we use this in the type one
in the in the reporter assays that i
mentioned before we can see that while
the wild type of 7a
can can block interference signaling uh
there is the the mutant has less ability
of block this interference response
suggesting again that ubiquitination of
this orb7 um
can also affect uh
how
um or seven antagonizes the response
so with this i i i think i have shown
you you know there are multiple virus
viruses that are affecting are
are
interacting with the host response so
the ubiquitin system has a huge role in
maintaining homeostasis and and regular
functions of the cell um disposal of
unwanted proteins in cell normally like
you can see on the right that this you
can think this as stream 6 and 37 having
anti normal antibiotic roles
having effects on antiviral c in in
immune signaling and other types of
signaling that maintain
the host healthy but then you have all
of these other effects on the left side
that the viruses are interacting with
these factors that are normally
antiviral um and either destroying them
like for the example of m and stream six
or taking advantage of them skyjacking
them to to allow ubiquiti nation to to
to to help them to replicate
so with this i i'll finish and i i'll
thank
you know multiple people that were have
been involved during the years in all of
these projects the people in my lab um
that i mentioned during the talk uh
collaborations this work would not have
been able to be done without the
collaborations of all the people within
bsl4 alexander freiberg um
alexander brooke bucharev uh peyongshi
for all the zika zika and koftu
experiments and there were a lot of uh
collaborators that helped making the
knockout diction seven knuckle mice uh
sanjia best juani mori provided mice
team knuckle mice ben hurley for the
nipa virus and
i'll finish and take questions if there
thank you so much dr rajman for that
informative presentation and we will now
begin the live q a portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
it looks like we already have some great
questions coming in
our first question what determines the
type of linkage of the poly ubiquitin
chains and what makes
k-48 or k-63 poly ubiquitin chains
um
great thanks thanks for that question um
um so so this is actually an uh an
interesting point um as i mentioned
there are about 40
e2
conjugates conjugating enzymes encoded
by the human genome and in general is
the e2 conjugates conjugating enzyme the
one that is responsible for making the
type of polyorbiting chain
uh so you need the con the the
association or the interaction of the e2
enzyme with the e3 ligase and the e2 is
the one that it decides where to put
that we put in
on the
other ubiquitin to make the polyurethane
chains um some of them are promiscuous
and can make different types of
polyurethane chains but there are some
some of them are more specific and can
make only one type of polybutane chain
so it's usually the two conjugating
enzyme the one that decides what type
of polyurethane chain is made
thank you so much and we have another
question coming in why does the virus
require ubiquinone to
enter the cell
in the case of zika virus and do other
viruses also contain ubiquitin that
helps them enter those cells
yeah so this is also a
an excellent question and um
this is something that we we are we have
been studying just lately so it's not
really
much known about the mechanisms or how
or why the virus would want to have
ubiquitin on on on the virion um
so as i said for for zika virus uh the
ubiquitination of the envelope protein
in the virus is not really required for
entry but it helps the virus to enter
the cell so we what we think is that
having the presence of somalic within
chains in the virion on the envelope
protein this helps
enhance the affinity
of the envelope protein to interact with
the receptors um in in our case we
tested team one so somehow we don't know
exactly
at the molecular level but
the interaction of ubiquitin
with the receptor helps
the envelope binds better and we do know
so far
at least one other virus that can
contain liquid in individual this is
influenza that has been reported that
contains inside can contain inside the
wire and the virion uh non-commonly
attached should be within but this
apparently helps the virus in a
completely different way to zika
apparently when influenza virus enters
the cell this ubiquitin helps the
encoding of the virus to release the
genome in the cytoplasm and so far there
are no other viruses that we know of
that contain liquid tin
but we do think that other viruses
um
uh might contain a liquid in that may
help them enter the cell and um it's
it's difficult to study so that's
probably why people have not found them
dr rajban this has been a great
presentation thank you so much for your
time and for your important research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience before we go
yeah so i mean thank you all for
attending uh this century this session
um i think one of the
points i want to make is that
yes we are in
povet time and we are all really paying
a lot of attention
and more attention on viruses
uh
but there are other viruses out out
there that we are not paying attention
right now and i don't know if anybody
has heard but there is an outbreak right
now in asia
of nepa virus uh this a lot of people
think that this could be potentially a
future pandemic even though um you know
this virus is really highly pathogenic
and
kills people
so maybe
makes it more difficult to transmit
um
but
we should we should continue paying
attention to other viruses that are out
there
i think something came in
um
um sure we we can throw in one more
question um this question says i'm not
sure if you're aware but the zika virus
protein are made as a polypeptide
translated into the er is it possible
that what you are observing with loss of
ubiquination of the
glycoprotein is a change in the
trafficking of the immature gp and
release of
aberrantly um
glycosylated gp which alters the
interactions with leptin binding
proteins such as what you've shown
yeah i mean thanks for this question
this is a great question and obviously
when we were doing these experiments we
were concerned about this that
ubiquitination
does occur inside the cell
and we do think that actually where the
the region in the cell where this is
occurring is
in somewhere in the between the er and
the golgi so yes there could be a
possibility that the ubiquitination
would be altering um
trafficking processing or or release of
the virus but actually we tested this
during our experiment
um
and and we did not see the mutant
viruses any difference in the release of
the virion compared to wild viruses so
we do not think that the ubiquitination
on the envelope is affecting at least in
major
it doesn't have major effects in the
release
ubiquitination of the envelope could
have other effects during the
replication of the virus
also depending on which of the two sides
uh are objected in the k-38 or the k-281
so um there is still a possibility that
there are some effects in trafficking
and in release but we do not think that
the mutant virus
um
the k-38 our mutant virus has a defect
in in in trafficking or or the the um
how how the binions uh become mature and
are released
um
i hope that answered us that question
dr rajvan thank you so much for your
time again today
and for your important research and
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast will be viewed on demand for two
years until september 9 2023
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone and stay healthy bye